e
good morning everybody time to get to
work welcome to the April 22nd edition
of the science technology and energy
committee and happy Earth Day to
everyone let's all rise and join
representative Corman as he leads us in
allegiance to the flag of the United
States of America and to the rep for
which it stands one nation God
okay so this morning we have a couple of
uh things to do we're going to have a
work session full committee work session
on three
Bills starting right now those three
bills are Senate Bill 603 Senate Bill
386 and Senate Bill
449 and
then at roughly 10:30 we're going to
start an executive session on the those
same three bills there may be if we have
time a recess for caucus at around 10:00
or 10:15 if
necessary so let's get
started by taking a look at Senate Bill
this amendment was sent to everyone on
Friday so you should have all had the
opportunity to review it and consider
it this bill makes a few changes to the
bill none that are particularly
significant but all that all the changes
are important to someone so we'll go
through those the very first
change was requested by house leadership
it reduces the communication Services
tax from 7 to
6.5% that's to cover any possible
increases in revenues that are raised by
this
legislation if you go to page
two
lines starting at line8 halfway through
line eight it says the department May
specially assess
these providers for the costs of
Investigations and other proceedings
regarding telephone number conversation
which should be
conservation pursuant to RSA 365 colon
37 comma 2 regardless of their
participation in any
proceeding that is language that appears
to extend the Department's ability to
and the way the language is
written after it was amended it
restricts that uh expansion just to this
particular
proceeding so it is probably not going
to raise anybody's costs but house
leadership felt that it would be prudent
to reduce the communication services is
tax by a half a percent just in case to
cover any potential cost
increases and uh I believe those are the
made so I would like to hear if anybody
has
any comments questions about this
amendment representative McGee thank you
Mr chairman um my reading of the um
testimony that we received in hearing
the only real opposition came from
ctia and they had a concern around uh
additional charges that this process
would incur that would be passed on to
their customers and I notice in the
section on page two starting at line8
that you read it says the department May
specially assess these providers for the
costs of Investigations and other
proceedings regarding telephone number
conservation it if we're going to change
that word to conservation uh pursuant to
RSA 365 colum 37 regardless of their
participation in any proceeding and I
guess what I'm concerned about is Will
these will this um smaller configuration
of
organizations be included in any
proceeding or that or will they just get
the charges out of the proceeding
because I think that's um somewhat
somewhat where their concern was and
somewhat where my concern would be the
larger telephone operators don't seem to
be
opposed um but the smaller folks that
are uh part of ctia do seem to have a
concern that it would the wording in
their letter is we are concerned that
this bill would place an additional and
unnecessary burden on the companies that
are already working in good faith with
the Department of energy to conserve
numbering
resources um and they're saying that
there were previous attempts to delay
the exhaust of the area codes in 2000
and 2011
uh were successful without requiring an
assessment based on members of the
industry so that the that's the only
issue I think that we should discuss
well let's ask the department since they
are here if you guys could come up
please and give us
um some guidance on that language we'd
appreciate
it and good morning to you
all good morning Mr chairman members of
the committee for the record my name is
Chris Elms I'm the Deputy Commissioner
of the New Hampshire Department of
energy and I'm joined by Amanda Nunan
director of uh consumer services at the
department I'm going to let uh Amanda
you know answer this probably more
accurately than I will I'll just say
there are two separate issues there and
and and one of the ones that we I don't
have the amendment I'm sorry I haven't
seen the amendment but we had suggested
language uh to resolve the the the
question about um those folks who have
not chosen to participate in Thousand
block pooling and that was a separate
issue that than the assessment language
so um I'll let Amanda talk
about
that sure thank you good morning um the
CTI is the cellular
telecommunications industry Association
I believe I have each letter right it's
roughly correct um and it consists of
large carriers such as T-Mobile Verizon
Wireless and small cellular carriers as
well so it's very big names within the
cellular
industry and the perhaps the the the the
small um adjective is better for the
testimony about the thousands block
pooling which came from the New
Hampshire telephone Association and the
small Rural Telephone
providers and and I I will just note
that so this this amendment um did
include just two other things that we
had suggested um representative Vose it
removed
uh language um and I'm looking the uh
Roman 2 on page
128 um down to line 29 where it says to
the maximum extent Allowed by federal
law for area code
603 the previous version uh of this bill
included a clause that said and any
subsequently assigned New Hampshire area
codes which has been stricken makes it
clear that this is just about the
603 uh and then going down a couple
lines I'm sorry I'm uh so line 30 and 31
ensuring that all service providers that
have chosen to participate in thousands
block pooling that H that that phrase
that have chosen to participate in
thousands block pooling that is a new
Clause that that um resolves I believe
the uh the the question raised by Mr
Rand uh in the public hearing New
Hampshire telephone
Association go ahead representative
McGee thank you Mr chairman and thank
you Mr Ms for my answering my question
um and for being here today I I guess
then the question would be if you choose
not to participate are you still subject
to the assessment is everyone subject to
the assessment is that I'm going to to
Amanda on that based on the language
here
sure
uh all providers are using telephone
numbers and so all providers using
telephone numbers would then pay towards
um this consultant contract which we'd
use the special assessment Provisions
for um to fund so yes that's the short
answer and the long answer okay I I will
just point out that um you know of you
know uh in in the 603 area code right
there are 10 million potential numbers
that could be used when you take out
ones that you you can't use uh ones that
have 911 in them things like that uh
there are about 7.8 Million numbers that
that potentially could be used in the
world um of of the ones that are
allocated out out in the world and and
I'm sorry I don't have the the best math
here but if you uh if you take the cost
of this consultant contract at the high
end $300,000 and you divide it by the 7
million or so numbers that are allocated
out in the world uh it looks like
something like a penny and a half per
line per year of control just so you can
have a sense of the um the costs we're
talking about
here additional questions representative
Ms thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question I have I have I have
a series of questions if you don't if
the chair would just indulge me all
related to one thing okay go ahead um so
the um
my my assumption is that the assessment
that we're talking about would be to pay
for the consultant is that correct yeah
so the assessment in this case and I'll
let Amanda um fill in what I what I
don't uh answer well uh that is the cost
of the consultant to help us in the
proceeding that we would open um or that
we have opened here so uh you know we
call it an investigation but that is you
know it's a little more in- depth than
just looking into it you know we we are
going to undertake actions through that
investigation that allow us to move
forward um it's it's you know we we've
brought up the examples of other states
um it's it's one of those things where
you know it's difficult but it's not
hard type of type of conversations right
in the same way that if you want to go
on a hike of a presidential Traverse
right it's simple to know what you need
to do you know the mountains you see the
trail maps you can read about all the
things that you might want to do but at
the same time you have to get in shape
you have to buy all the equipment that
you want want to do and you know go
through it so we know broadly the
direction we need to go here we know a
lot of the steps that we can take but we
also have to undertake what's a pretty
Technical and and uh collaborative
process and and the the fiscal note
indicated that the cost of that
consultant could be between hundred and
two
$300,000 that's what we're talking about
over over three years and and divided
amongst all the okay and then what I
understood was that the reduction in the
communications tax was so to compensate
for the extra the extra cost of the
assessment how much how much do we
collect in Communications tax so on the
Communication Service tax I I will have
to defer that to other other folks that
you know um that is a a general fund tax
we don't get any revenue from the
Communication Service tax at the
department of energy um I don't know
what what that equals on your average
bill but it's a 7%
tax on on on those Communications so I
can't give you the number um Dr might be
able to yeah and I guess I guess and
this is the the the where I was really
going with the question is is the the
0.5%
reduction um is
that does that result in a
reduction is is that is is that
reduction in revenues equivalent to
what's going to be spent for the for the
for the consultant
so and and that 0.5 reduction is ongoing
it's not just for three years so I'm
trying to do the
math you would have to have somebody
else help you with the math there I
would
say that I would imagine it is a a a
greater reduction through the
communication Services tax than it would
be uh any any costs associated with the
assessment that which you know we we
would be clear are are not necessarily
tied together the Communication Service
tax does not benefit the department uh
you know from a revenue perspective
that's a it's a general fund uh tax
whereas the assessment is is housed
within the department so so the redu a
reduction in the in the communication
tax is going to impact programs across
the board uh across All State agencies I
mean it could end up having an impact on
what we're able to spend
for I don't know
um you know Assist assistance to
low-income people I
mean you know I I don't want to comment
on that as it's it's sort of out of my
Lane that was more of a rhetorical
question thank you I didn't want to put
you in the spot there further questions
representative
Summers thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question mine is actually
when I read this bill and and also the
amendment I was concerned about and I I
think I understand it but I wanted to
ask if this bill and Amendment include
Does it include any goal especially with
the pooling any goal towards detering or
blocking spam or auto dialer businesses
numbers um that's certainly one thing
that we anticipate looking at is the use
of numbers um outside of the State of
New Hampshire not necessarily by people
that got a cell phone when they lived
here and moved but for use for
commercial Purp pures outside of the
State of New Hampshire at the federal
level there's been um a a lot of work
over the past 4 to five years to
implement a number of measures uh
certainly there's more that can be done
in looking at cyber crime and the use of
these numbers is is something that we
investigation resentative n has a
question well I did but I figured it out
so thank
you representative the wiki uh thank you
Mr chairman um and I this may or may not
be appropriate to this bill um however
coming from my background I say why can
we not just do something simple take all
of the telephone 603 numbers that are in
Ed do a diff between that and all of the
possible numbers and out will fall
another file which is all of the unused
numbers and we can assign those rather
than depending upon some fossilized
agency like nanpa to do it we just tell
them okay we've got all these recycled
numbers let's use them uh I'll let the
department comment on that if they
choose
to so the the North American numbering
plan administrator is the administrator
of numbers ac across the country and
they have all that information states
have limited insight into uh resources
and numbers but certainly not to the
extent that you described and that would
have to be something that was done at a
federal
level representative bernardy has a
question thank you Mr chair so uh I
received a uh a comment from
representative alvinc who is here right
now and he suggested in part of the
assessment that the uh um numbers that
are used for security alarm systems
Pages for volunteer EMS uh and fire
folks that are Auto dialed from a
dispatcher um self-based cameras that
can use up to six numbers at a time
simultaneously none of those uh are
numbers that are would be used in
preserving the 603 Mystique for for
residents they they outgoing calls and
and uh Auto automated often times and
there are others potentially in that
same boat um can your uh
assessment be directed to look at those
and potentially reassign those folks
other
numbers so that's certainly something
that um we could look at as part of this
um engagement with a consultant I would
note that on a national level there's an
effort it's called iot or Internet of
things which isn't a very explanatory um
term but it it looks at exactly what
you're describing and all the
non telephone uses of telephone numbers
and that's a very massive undertaking at
the federal level because it's not
unique to New Hampshire it's across the
representative Ms has another question
thank you this is actually just one
question this time um the um the the
bill um as introduced and and I don't
think the amendment changes it repeals
the language and existing statute that
talks about the the the the procedure or
the guidelines that should be used if a
new area code is
needed um that's section six in the uh
in the in the RSA um I mean given what
what I think we heard which is even if
we implement this uh even if we
implement this language and are able to
um you know preserve the the uniqueness
of the 603 that's only going to be for a
while I mean eventually we're going to
need a new area
code um I I guess I'm it just doesn't
seem prudent to me to eliminate language
that would guide us when we actually
have to assign A New U area code
sure uh that language was um stricken to
reflect just change circumstances since
that language was originally put into
statute so when the National Suicide
Prevention Hotline was um rolled out and
I I forget the three-digit number that
folks dial for that um it pushed New
Hampshire to go to 10 digigit dialing
and once you've made the move to 10
digigit dialing the two options for
implementing a new area code are reduced
to one which is an overlay where you
simply there's a new area code and it
lays over the whole state versus a
geographic split where people squabble
over who gets 603 and who gets the new
area
code representative
McGee um my question was back on the
assessment and penalties so we're back
up in section three on page two and um I
think you know we've sort of established
that the fiscal note is related to the
role of a consultant coming in to try
and devise a plan for us to move forward
on figuring out how to conserve and
preserve numbers and elongate our
ability to have 603 as our our uni uh
area code but it also says here uh
starting on line a the department May
spe specially assess these providers for
the costs of Investigations which I'm
assuming is the consultant fees and
other uh proceedings regarding telephone
number conversions pursuant to RSA
3652 regardless of their participation
in any proceedings which I read before
and then it goes on to say service
providers shall be subject to penalties
imposed by the department or commission
for failure to pay a special assessment
or for failure to comply with any rule
or order so out of this uh assessment
proceeding do you anticipate that there
will be specific rules or orders that
folks will do do you have any idea what
kind of rules or orders may end up
creating assessments for the
companies because I'm assuming the
language is in here for a reason I don't
have a specific example to point to but
ju as a general example if there were a
directive that um carriers participate
in in um voluntary exchange of
blocks that are more than 10%
contaminated which is the Benchmark for
returning a block to the pool at Nampa
but um less than 15% contaminated that
they voluntarily agree to transfer those
blocks among one another rather than
getting a new block out of the pool that
okay further
questions or comments about this bill
representative Corman thank you Mr
chairman yes I have a comment um every
now and then I agree with something that
representative Harrington has said and
uh he said something last week that I do
agree with where he and and uh
representative Harrington please uh
correct me if I'm uh mischaracterizing
what you said uh but you were wondering
um we're going to run out of numbers
eventually
ually
and why go through this exercise when
we're going to run out of numbers it's
just going to happen and all we're doing
is delaying the inevitable and that's my
concern with the bill I I will vote for
the amendment because I think the
amendment makes the bill better but I I
really think the bill is unnecessary as
we are going to run out of numbers no
do representative Harrington would like
to respond yeah I agree that's what I
said and I do agree we're going to run
out of number eventually and of course
that means since we agree the Patriots
are going to have a great draft um but
uh I in talking with the people on this
I think the attempt here is to delay
running out until we go to the what is
it 15 digits or something like that so
this may extend it out to that part when
we're going to make a major change
anyways and the hope is that it will
this will last long enough so we don't
have to make two
changes I think that's correct isn't it
I if if I may just give that certainly
that question there um you know like
like I said before we we have been able
to look at and see what other states
have been able to do Maine was in a even
more dire situation than the one we're
in now back in 2021 where they were
projected to exhaust in 2024 now um
after undertaking a lot of their efforts
I think their projected exhaustion is in
the early 2030s um so they've already
seen some success and I think they they
think they're going to be able to extend
it out even further our hope would be
would be that we would be able to extend
the life of this the 603 so that that
that that question about 15 digigit
dialing is what gets rid of the area
exhaustion okay thank you uh
representative
Ms um I I I was going to initially agree
with representative Corman but then
having heard representative Harrington
hell has frozen over because I agree
with him as well um that you know we
might as well we might as well try to um
to um you know save the the area code as
as long as possible the one thing that I
have a problem with and I think this is
where I differ with representative
Corman is I will not vote for the
amendment because I do not believe that
we should be reducing the communication
Services tax um I don't think it's
related to this uh this
initiative um but um I will I I I will
vote for the the amendment if that I the
passed okay any further comments
representative Thomas thank you Mr chair
um in listening to this discussion and I
got here a little late and I apologize
um it feels like the opposition to
changing 603 is similar to the
opposition of changing the exit numbers
on the highways and um in some ways
isn't it just time that we we accept the
vintage well obviously um and thank you
for the question it's it's a good one
it's it is the legislative prerogative
to determine sort of what that
prioritization is um we have seen you
know and and I know the Department of
Business and economic Affairs is
undertaking a study on this but there
are economic uh benefits you know I I
think the 603 is undeniably
you know something associated with New
Hampshire in in an iconic way and the um
it it really is up to the legislature to
say is this something that my
constituents would care about you know
from what we've heard we we would think
that it it it might be certainly um but
that's obviously up to you as a as a
determine okay seeing no further comment
I think we have discussed senator Bill
603 to the degree that we need to I
think we have a pretty good idea of
where we're headed with that bill so now
let's discuss Senate Bill
386 and I am passing out an amendment to
moment and I will Begin by reminding the
members that when we heard the testimony
by Senator avard on this bill
he said to
us please give me a study
committee he wants a study
committee
he was less sure about what the subject
of the study committee should
so I have prepared the amendment 1558 h
to create a study
committee to study the creation of a
pamphlet or website for incoming
legislators and the public on the basics
of New Hampshire energy law regarding
energy regulation Alternative Energy
Supply renewable energy net metering and
Energy
Efficiency the makeup of the committee
will be the same as in the original bill
but the duties of the committee will be
different
the committee will study the creation of
a pamphlet or online site for incoming
legislators and the public to learn the
basics of New Hampshire energy law and
shall include a brief history of the New
Hampshire Energy Arena describe where
energy comes from and the basics of any
of utility regulation and how to
understand energy bills describe and
Define the state's mix of energy
describe consumer options for energy
procurement describe the regional grid
including transmission and distribution
and Define front SL behind the meter
describe the differences between
traditional and renewable energy
resources and how the state supports
clean energy sources describe net
metering and other consumer Alternatives
describe Energy Efficiency and
conservation describe Community
aggregation discuss discuss the role of
battery storage of renewable energy
discuss the costs of energy and the
trade-offs associated with all types of
energy
production and finally include any other
Concepts crucial to understanding the
New Hampshire energy landscape so that's
what the the new bill will do or the new
study committee will do and I'm
interested to hear comments from the
committee representative
Corman thank you Mr chairman um it
sounds like a lot of fun to do this um
but I'm wondering uh this looks like a
non- gerain amendment to me and I'm
wondering about about
that I don't think it is because it it
follows the same form it just changes
the content of what the study committee
will do I can check with the clerk but I
I think it will be appr appropriate and
approved representative
Kennedy thank you Mr chairman uh you
know we just finished discussing a bill
for the Department of energy that as far
as I can tell has nothing to do with
energy whatsoever so I I have no idea
why the department of energy is doing
that but this this particular bill I
mean it's the same question I had for
the senator was why can't the department
of energy prepare a report this seems
like something the department of energy
you know could
do well this is a study committee and
the study committee's recommendation may
be for the Department of energy to
produce this pamphlet or online site
based on recommendations that they come
up with that would be one of the options
that the the uh study committee could
could
recommend who else had their heading up
representative
nter I was a freshman legislator with
Senator Kevin avard he was a State Rep
first back in 2010 and he's our singing
Senator and so I have a lot of respect
for him and normally I just
automatically give a thumbs down to a
study because we have so many but if
it'll make make him happy and it makes
it's energy made easy and it will they
Define all these word all these letters
for new legislators like pu D OE d s RPS
Reggie and goes on and on and I remember
being new to this committee and I had no
idea what anybody was talking about
until one day pu I'm like oh I know that
one so I think it's a good
idea representative Harrington yeah I
think um certainly uh I agree with the
previous speaker that there's a lot of
Confusion And there's a lot of uh um
presumed knowledge that's not accurate
shall we say by a lot of people and so
this kind of covers most everything but
as as I said in the comment I sent out
over the weekend I really think we need
to get a little more specific that we
need to address ISO no England and the
role they play because that is clearly
misunderstood some people think they're
an agency of the federal government some
people think they're uh some agency of
Massachusetts or something I I mean I've
heard all sorts of different things why
don't we just get out of there we don't
need need them uh so what how they're
involved in the process and the fact
that they are a utility that's regulated
by FK um a lot of people don't even know
that basic fact so I just think putting
something specific in there about ISO
New England would be would be helpful
just so it's not
overlooked you think the lines 25 and 26
would be adequate to that
purpose I mean if you you if you want to
if you look at that and you expand on it
drastically you would obviously get into
ISO New England but it's such an
important concept I think calling it out
in the bill uh is would be helpful
because I mean it is a big player and a
lot of people have no idea what the
interaction is who they regulated by and
so yes okay further comments
representative
parshall thank you chair I generally
agree with the comments of of the last
two speakers um I think where I'm might
want to take exception is spending tax
payer dollars taxpayer dollars pardon me
to uh keep Senators happy I don't think
it's our function to that's uh you know
I I just I just find that not within
something which I would want to get
behind but I do agree that a good
glossery would help go a long ways in
helping dispel a lot of things I would
also agree that ISO is an important part
of this I think there's a number part
number of important parts that I hope
would come out in the study um I just
don't know if this uh if we're dealing
with when it comes to policy too much of
a shifting slope to really create
anything of any lasting
permanence representative Thomas thank
you Mr chair um along the lines of the
previous speaker um this kind of feels
like Reinventing the wheel there's lots
of good documents already that are out
there you can look on Amazon there's
lots of good books about energy energy
is literally in flux and it changes on
an almost daily basis this report and
really what it is is just a research
paper uh is outdated probably the day
that it's
published thank you representative
Corman thank you Mr chairman uh I
actually think it would be a really nice
primer for new members of the committee
I I think I would have appreciated
having a document like this when I came
on at the beginning of last year but I
also want to say that um the the uh
thought expressed by representative
Harrington about ISO New England
unbelievable but I had the very same
thought um I saw the part about the
regional grid but I thought ISO New
England is a lot bigger than that for
example it runs the energy auctions and
and I think that needs to be in there so
um uh twice in one day I'm agreeing with
representative Harrington uh take that
for what you will representative liwi uh
thank you um we've got this st& jargon
jogger which is really a brief version
say that again please um we had this
document passed out stn jargon uh jargon
jogger um which I've got right here in
front of me which is a brief version of
exactly what we're talking about it's
got uh basically expands the acronyms
and just going a little beyond that
would be probably enough for a lot of
people okay further
comments representative
mutts thank you
um I don't believe a a study committee
is is necessary I mean I I think any
everything that's that's um identified
in this in this amendment could easily
be uh provided by either the department
of energy the Department of
Environmental Services in in a in a in a
in a report you know every two years
that is given to you know all new and
and um well all all Representatives so a
St I don't believe a study committee is
going to add any
value representative McGee thank you Mr
chairman um I think we had a little bit
of an offline on this and um I know I
sent points along in terms of the
composite of how New Hampshire energy
the sector works I think it is helpful
for people coming on to the committee to
have some context around um you know how
the how deregulation works works you
know the stuff that is sort of in
between the lines that you don't get
until you've been on the committee for a
long time is really helpful but um how
you get that information is another
question I since I've been on the
committee I know that the the jargon
jogger or the you know acronym list
which I worked on a little bit with doe
they were putting one together we were
putting one together we and we you know
added them together to to get something
to folks we've been providing that on in
our caucus and we've been also providing
individual training for new people
coming online and it's ad hoc it's
people who are experts in different
areas like net metering or whatever
because when people come in they know
the term and that's really all they know
um but it is very ad hoc and so I think
there's also a significant amount of
information that the department of
energy provides to us so they do an RPS
report they have a 10-year strategy
report there are a lot of things
available on their website already that
people could familiarize themselves with
if they wanted to spend the time to read
all of those things and I think that's
the problem is that people don't read as
much as they used to and they and they
may not want to put the time into all of
that voluminous information so I I I'm
torn on this I I I think not a lot will
get done between uh when this passes and
November 1st so I'm not sure a fome
report can really be done which I
brought up in the hearing it's a short
amount of time it's an election year I
don't know what the participation will
be like and I don't know how well it
will will be led so I I am also uh torn
as to whether this should just be
something that goes to the Department of
energy to provide um an O an overview
space of New Hampshire energy I I think
that makes a lot of
sense well the study committee could
recommend that representative
Harrington yeah I I tend to agree with
the previous speakers that I think the
department of is capable of doing this
without and probably would do a better
job at it because let's face it they're
here fulltime during the summer we tend
to be of any place but the state house
so uh I think you probably get in a
better uh uh effort that way and also if
you do um have a study committee just to
say we recommend the department of
energy do this I mean is that just sort
of a waste of paper but on the on the
final thought regardless of how it's
done uh as one of the previous speakers
mentioned I don't think this should be a
policy documented at all it shouldn't be
trying to say we should do this or do
that or not do this it should just be a
statement of facts saying you know this
is the function of iso New England this
is how net metering Works uh this is
what the forward capacity Market auction
is and not not make a statement on
whether it's good bad or indifferent
which is just to be an educational tool
but I I still think the department of
energy could probably put out a better
product further
comment representative Kaplan thank you
Mr chair is it possible to ask the
department of energy how this would fit
into any kind of communications outreach
program that they already have I me
because I I can see this as a as a
wonderful educational tool for the
general public not necessarily for the
state reps but maybe something they
already have or maybe they have a
thought on whether that would be useful
or not would anybody from the Department
question uh thank you Chris Al from the
Department of energy um
I think as been as has been mentioned a
number of the requirements here are
currently available on our website um
you know this bill just the position we
would take is we'd be happy to
participate in any study committee that
would look at whether or not there
should be a collected aggregated report
that we would include I think there are
a number of resources that we have again
on our website on uh you know uh the
utilities websites on the pu's websites
um in our our state energy strategy
uh if if folks want to aggregate that
together we'd be happy to discuss what
like thank
you further comments representative
McGee the last thing I'll say is if if
our goal is just to keep Senator avard
happy he did say we could make it just
storage and he would be
happy so if we don't want to make it
into you know a huge
exercise I person Al don't want to do
another amendment but representative uh
Harrington just one other thing that uh
just again no matter how it's done
whether it's a study committee or or we
just task the department to do it and
one of the issues that always comes up I
probably get more phone calls and emails
on this than any other subject to do
with energy is what's a competitive
supplier how do you get one will then is
that mean if my wires go down that those
mean people from uh ever Source won't
put them back up because I don't buy
their my electricity from them and they
all know it so I mean I think that's
something that really needs to be
included because I I think the average
state repc gets asked that question and
they don't know where to go to find a
competitive supplier for one of their
constituents and they don't realize that
the utility still owns all the wires and
there's no change to it and the person
restringing the wires has no idea
whether you're buying the electricity
from ever Source or a competitive
supplier or whatever so I just think
it's something should be could be and
now we have a nonprofit so we should be
how Okay further comments representative
n ke Senator avar did say um something
about storage here in committee but down
in the lobby when I was talking to him
he also said he'd be happy with um a
study on
incinerating debris and trash like like
well
okay so I just checked my email and the
amendment for Senate Bill 449 has just
been delivered to my
inbox so I have forwarded that to
Christie and asked her to make copies so
that could probably take 10 or 15
minutes so why don't we take a recess
right now and if either side wants to
cck us you can you can go do
that um let's get back here at say 10 10
you we could ask everybody to clear the
it
e
okay everybody's back so now we can take
up the final matter of our work session
and I will pass that
out to everyone whoops I forgot to keep
you okay Senate Bill
449 relative to the permit issuance
timeline for State air per and the
Department of Environmental Services
duty to make annual reports it's
Amendment
15658 and this is an amendment that I'm
told was agreed to by the department and
the business and industry
Association is I'm seeing nods from
members of the department and the Bia so
I'm assuming that I'm correct about that
that this is a mutually agreed
Amendment and what the amendment
does primarily is it adds new language
starting at line 24 through line 32
reporting and I've forgotten if it does
anything
else um could the department clarify
me Craig Wright uh Dees uh the
department does support the amendment
what it changes is the timeline for
permanent issuance on line 12 previously
it said 180 days now it says 120 days
and we are okay with that change uh and
also changes on line 15 the reference
there 40 CFR
70.4
B6 it changed that six to a six from a
four so it clarified that Federal
reference and then it adds the annual
reporting requirement at the end of the
bill
sir great thanks for refreshing my
memory about that so do we have any
amendment well it would appear we do not
so thank you for being here to help
clarify things for
us so are there any comments if there
are no questions are there any comments
do you find yourself in general to be
amendment representative McGee yeah my
only comment would be that
um the thing that was outstanding when
we ended the hearings was that the we
wanted the parties to be agreed upon
what change was needed and it looks like
that's what we have in our hands so I'm
okay representative Corman can can we
hear from the representative of the
morning I can just speak to I didn't
know if you had any questions um yes so
this change um does alleviate our
concerns we feel that the 120 days is
much more workable especially for small
business um the other change on line 15
is just a technical correction so no
issues there and then um the new
reporting section um just provide some
more transparency it's my understanding
that um Dees already kind of collects
this data so just if we could review it
to make sure that the timelines are
operating on a timely manner which I I
believe at this time that they are but
it just allows that transparency for the
business
Community great thank you representative
Corman thank you and thank you for
taking my question so uh when we had the
hearing last week there was discussion
about maybe two tracks one for smaller
businesses one for larger businesses you
feel that 120 days one siiz fits-all is
okay thank you for the question um we do
believe this is the best solution going
forward um Dees experts I believe looked
at trying to create du uh dual tracks as
well as experts in our membership it was
incredibly complex difficult to do and
hard to find a reasonable place to draw
the line um simply because you know for
example like the title five permits that
we didn't touch the timeline of um need
that more time and we recognized that so
we felt that this was the most
reasonable way to move forward
representative
Kennedy uh thank you Mr chairman thanks
for taking my question um I I the the
part of the bill that uh uh requires a
report going to the two committees I
mean do do you think that's going to be
an adequate uh mechanism if you have
some complaints about how this is
working thank you for the question um we
think that that's an opportunity to
review that data and if there's a need
for change in legislation that um
potentially bringing it to the attention
of um the two committees who this would
be in the purview of um would be a
reasonable path moving forward if there
necessary uh representative Harrington
yeah thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my questions more of a comment I
guess my major concern with the bill was
the lack of that reporting uh in the
original one the way it's was written
you have a certain amount of time to get
the permit unless the applicant says
we'll give you extra time so if the
agency says well we can't do it unless
you give us extra time it sort of forces
them into a situation where they can't
win because the agency could simply say
well then you don't get your permit
unless you give us extra time but having
the reporting there so that the
legislature could look at it and say you
know 90% of the permits are running over
120 days what's going on or hopefully
it's going to be 2% of the permits were
going over 120 days and they were all
because the applicant needed more time
for something so I think adding that in
is a big uh big plus to the Bill thank
you representative and actually that was
one of our concerns as well and in our
discussions with Dees they um assured us
that permits cannot be denied based on
timeline issues and that was one of our
concerns it just based on the statutes
it can't happen so I think that
complements
that any further questions for Miss K
representative muns thank you Mr chair
and thank you for taking my question um
in your in your testimony on this bill
um I I I give you a lot of credit for
identifying what I think is one of the
um fundamental reasons why the
department has challenges in terms of um
fulfilling its requirements under the
stat under statute and that's a lack of
Le resources um are you convinced that
they have the resources to meet the
120-day
requirement um thank you for the
question I don't want to speak for the
Department especially when they're here
behind me but this wasn't a a an
amendment that we came to an agreement
on
together follow up yeah and I I just
wanted to clarify I should have said
this before I am in no way suggesting
that the the department that you know is
um is not trying to do the very best job
they can with the resources that they
have uh I'm very aware of the fact that
Dees as well as other state agencies
have been operating for years with out
the resources that they need so I just
KO seeing none I want to thank you thank
you we still have a few minutes left in
our work session are there any general
comments about this amendment to Senate
Bill
449 okay seeing
none any further comments about the
other two bills Senate Bill 603 or
Senate Bill
minutes representative Ms than thank you
Mr chair on um on 603 um as I as I
mentioned earlier I um I I will not be
able to vote for the amendment as it's
the amendment that you you're proposing
um primarily and only because of the um
the the inclusion of a reduction in the
communication Services tax um but I do
recognize that there are some other
important elements in the amendment that
you um that you have given us um and I
am in the process of trying to get a
separate amendment that hopefully we can
consider if your if your Amendment fails
that includes the language um that um I
think the um the rural uh providers were
looking for and also the the um the the
cell companies so um I just wanted to
give everyone a heads up to
that thank you representative McGee yeah
if I might just mention and when we went
and and talked um the concern was really
that the revenue uh from this tax goes
into the general fund and there are
going to be there's going to be some
lowering of revenu and you know
difficulties coming into finances in the
next year so the quantifying of how much
money this will affect and um what
effect it will have uh on the general
fund was an open question the other
question was should a bill that has a
fiscal note on it like this um have to
go to a second committee for a
discussion or understanding of that
fiscal impact so that's kind of the
conversation that we had around whether
or not we should should just be you know
making a cut of half a point to that tax
without having you know considered the
impacts uh on our ability to do other
things with that funding and um so I
guess since there is a pending um
additional Amendment for that bill I'd
ask that we maybe move it to the to the
third spot in order to give us time to
get that Amendment if if the uh
committee and the chair is so in
clined okay thank you further comment on
either of the other two bills that we're
considering I should point out that we
have
a uh a replacement for representative
McWilliams today that's representative
cloudier
welcome clud here sorry to mispronounce
it
welcome to the
committee all right sit tight the clerk
repeatedly tells us that you can start
an executive session after the noticed
time but you can't start it before the
noticed time so we still have seven
minutes to go before we can start our
executive session so just sit tight and
minutes
e
okay it is now 10:30 and so we can
officially start an exact session we
have three bills to dispose of excuse me
in the next
uh period of time however long it takes
Center Bill 603 relative to telephone
number and area code
conservation it's c a bill 386 relative
to establishing a committee to study
something and Senate Bill 449 relative
to the permit issue in timeline for
State air
permits so I'm going to open an exec
session first on Senate Bill
449 since that was the last one we
looked at right before
we finished our work session I think it
it's appropriate that it be the first
one that we take up and so I will move
65h and recognize Vice chair
Thomas second moved and seconded that we
adopt this
needed it appears that there is no
discussion needed so I would ask the
clerk to call the role on the question
Vice chair Thomas yes representative ner
yes representative Harrington yes
representative leeki yes representative
uh Bernardi yes representative PL yes
representative Summers yes
representative Kennedy yes
representative McGee yes representative
cluder yes representative crean yes
representative parall yes representative
Kaplan yes representative muns yes
representative Noel yes representative
Thomas yes representative Corman
yes
180 you may have oh chair V excuse me
180 okay by a vote of 18 to zero
Amendment 1565 H is adopted I now move
ought to pass as amended and recognize
Vice chair Thomas second moved and
seconded that we adopt house bill or
Senate Bill 449 as amended by Amendment
1565 H any further discussion
needed representative muns thank you Mr
chair um I voted I voted yes on the
amendment because I think it does make
the bill better and does um hopefully
address some of the concerns but um I
will be voting
against um otpa because um I do not
believe that we're addressing the
underlying reasons why it has been so
difficult to get uh permits approved
within the statutorily mandated time
frames further comments representative
Thomas um yes I would I would love to
see it less than 120 days however I will
be voting for this um especially as
there's agreement on both sides but to
representative mun's point if we had if
if Dees were had more resources it could
be even
comments representative Marshall thank
you chair I would re I would Echo uh
representive th Thomas's uh concern we
do need to do something to speak to uh
comments seeing none I'd ask the clerk
to call the question of
otpa on House Bill senate or Senate Bill
rather
449 Vice chair Thomas yes representative
naer yes oh yes representative
Harrington yes representative Wicky yes
representative re Bernardi yes
representative PL yes representative
Summers yes representative Kennedy yes
representative McGee yes representative
cluder yes representative cran no
representative parshall yes
representative Kaplan yes Representative
muns no representative Noel yes
represent restive Thomas yes
representative Corman yes chairman Vose
yes
162 by a vote of 16-
two I think they were three
right it appears to be right that the
vote was 16-2 in favor of ought to pass
as amended
I will write the committee report will
there be a Minority Report
representative muns will write The
Minority Report and I need that before
possible it it it might be in my H
scratching but I will get you something
that's okay H scratching works it will
not be on consent since it will have a
Minority Report and with that we'll
close the exec session on Senate Bill
9 and now we're going to open an exact
session on Senate Bill
396 and I will move the
adoption 386
sorry and I will move the adoption of
amendment 2024 D1
1558 H and recognize Vice chair Thomas
second moved and seconded that we adopt
the amend
Amendment
1558 H to Senate Bill 386 we had an
extensive discussion about this this
morning but I'm open to further comments
on the adoption of this
amendment representative Kaplan I think
the amendment uh thank you Mr chair I
think the amendment does make the bill
uh better um however I can't vote for it
because I do think that this is a job
that's better left to the Department of
energy and does not need a study
committee and I don't think that you
know it's consistent with our position
on uh allowing study committees to go
forward in the second year of the
comment well seeing none I'll ask the
clerk to call the role on the question
of the adoption of amendment
Vice chair Thomas yes representative ner
yes representative Harrington yes
representative licki
yes representative Bry yes
representative Bernardi yes
representative PL yes representative
Summers yes representative Kennedy yes
representative McGee no Representative
cluer no no representative Chan no
representative parshall yes
representative Kaplan no Representative
muns
no representative Noel no representative
11 one two three four five six seven
eight 11 to
eight okay by a vote of 11 to8 the
amendment 1558 H is
adopted I will now move ought to pass as
amended and recognize Vice chair Thomas
second moved in seconded that we adopt
cin Bill 386 as amended by Amendment 15
comments seeing none I ask the clerk to
call the role on the question of ought
386 Vice chair Thomas yes representative
not yes representative Harrington yes
representative licki yes representative
Bry yes representative Bernardi yes
representative PL yes representative
Summers yes representative Kennedy yes
representative McGee no Representative
cluder no representative cran no
Representative parall no representative
Kaplan no
Representative muns no representative
Noel no representative Thomas no
representative Corman
no cam V
nine by a vote of 10 to nine the motion
of O to pass as amended is
adopted and I will write the majority
report and will there be a minor
Minority
Report representative
McGee yeah I oh Tony wants to write it
representative Kaplan please
representative Kaplan will write The
Minority
Report and please deliver that before
possible okay with that we'll close the
exec session on Senate Bill
386 that leaves us with one bill left to
go so I'll open the exact session on
Senate Bill
603 relative to telephone number area
code conservation and adjusting the
inate communication Services
tax we discussed this bill extensively
in our work session this
morning
and I think we have a good understanding
of what the changes to the bill are and
why they might be
desirable but I'd open the floor to
further comments on Senate Bill 603 and
uh wait a minute I didn't move the amend
Amendment yet did I okay I move
Amendment 2024 1559 H and recognize Vice
chair Thomas second moved and seconded
that we adopt Amendment 2024
1559 H now let's have a discussion
representative Corman thank you Mr
chairman um I said earlier I would vote
for it for the amendment and against the
bill and that is my plan I will vote for
the amendment and against the bill I'm
not thrilled with the amendment I uh
understand the concern about lowering
the uh Communications tax without
understanding the implications but I
said I would vote for the amendment and
I shall vote for the
seeing none it looks like we can ask the
clerk to call the role on the question
of the adoption of the amendment 1559 H
603 Vice chair Thomas yes representative
n yes representative Harrington yes
representative licki yes representative
brne yes representative Bernardi yes
representative PL yes
representative Summers yes
representative Kennedy yes
representative McGee no Representative
cluder no Representative crean no
Representative parall
no representative Kaplan no
representative Ms no representative Noel
no representative Thomas no
representative Corman yes rep uh
118 by a vote of 11 to8 the amendment is
adopted I will now move ought to pass as
amended on Senate Bill 603 as amended by
Amendment 1559 H and recognized Vice
Cher Thomas second moved and seconded
that we adopt the motion about to pass
is
representative
Ms I will be uh voting no on uh otpa
which um is um is unfortunate because um
the the changes that were made to
section two of the original bill I
believe make the the bill a better bill
that addresses many of the concerns that
were raised during testimony
unfortunately with the amendment um and
the um the introduction of a reduction
in the um Interstate communication
Services tax which never came up during
our hearing and you know it just makes
the bill um untenable for me so
unfortunately I will be voting against
the
discussion seeing none it looks like we
can ask the
clerk oh sorry representative Corman
thank you Mr chairman I raised my hand
late uh yeah I'm still feeling like
we're just kicking the can down the road
and I understand that you know we might
be able to string out 603 until such
time as 15 digigit dialing God forbid
happens um but we also might not I just
feel like we're we're we're just
delaying the inevitable and um I'm I'm
going to vote against the
seeing none I'll ask the clerk to call
the role on the question about to pass
603 M shair Thomas yes representative
ner yes representative Harrington yes
representative licki yes representative
Bry yes representative Bernardi yes
representative PL yes representative
Summers yes representative Kennedy yes
representative McGee no Representative
cluder no representative cran no
Representative
parshall no representative Kaplan no
Representative muns no representative
Noel no representative Thomas no
representative Corman
no uh chairman Vose yes 10 to nine by a
vote of 10 to n the motion of ought to
pass as amended is adopted I will write
the majority report will there be a
Minority
Report representative Corman will write
The Minority
Report see if you could have that before
you leave
today
and with
that we will close the exact session on
Senate Bill
603 and that concludes our work for
today
excellent job
everybody I'm going to ask you all to
reserve next Monday the 29th of April
for a work session full committee work
session starting at 9 o'l and a
executive session starting at
10:30 on Senate Bill
395 and Senate Bill
451 those are the two Senate bills that
we still have outstanding
and we
will we've had
um this extensive discussions on both
those bills there are amendments coming
for both those bills we will try to get
them to all members before the weekend
so that you'll have time to study them
595 595 I think you're right did I say
395 yes my mistake yes 5 95 is the
correct
Bill does anybody have any uh
announcements or any news to offer to
the committee before we adjourn for the
day you said nine o'clock right nine
o'clock and then uh when was the exact
today okay seeing nothing um I want to
thank everybody for your hard work today
and we will see you next Monday take
care
here